[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classic hello chess fans the
action continues with round 2 of the
fall chess classic here in st. Louis
today group a featured only one decisive
game but Group B now has its first
decisive leader in Alejandra Ramirez
will talk to him later on today the
fields combined have a prize fund of
$36,000 the top prize in Group A is 6
grand
the top prize in Group B is 4 grand we
play one classical round of chess every
day through Thursday September 14 rounds
begin at 1 p.m. here in st. Louis except
for the last day which begins earlier a
big win in round number 2 for the
runner-up of this spring classic
grandmaster Yaroslav is there a book
thank you for joining me congratulations
on your win against another one of the
favorites in the field Tigran L
Petrosyan take us through the game and
show us what happened position looked
somewhat too radical but the difference
is that in main theory Bishop is somehow
on e3 instead of b2 I felt I felt pretty
comfortable here I thought rook c5 Queen
a8 it's what I saw was the bishop on e3
but I thought it was the bishop on b2 it
should be even better for black so I was
really comfortable about around this
point and then I guess I got kind of too
complacent like you know I got too happy
about my position and okay I was playing
more or less all right and then and then
at this point II five this objectively
I think just just a mistake
what kind of risky I would say it's too
risky to create so many weaknesses I
should have
just kept playing something solid maybe
double the rooks or just Knight c-54
something like something of the sort and
then another position is more or less
equal well probably equal is not the
right word but I mean balanced because
you can say equal because I mean still
be playing for three results
I wish let's say 95 I mean 95 and maybe
I can even take or you know just
probably take I mean it's a normally
white if the pawn was in g3 white is
better in such cases but when the point
is in g5 I guess I have play against it
so so we can say it's balanced more or
less and then here I get a gift from him
after h5 he played Queen Street really
quickly so I was kind of bluffing is a
ship where you believe this I mean he
should have just taken on h6 and then it
seems like white just has a really good
advantage because up tonight of six
queen h3 my initial idea was like Knight
h5 and I'm some reason I was happy about
my position but then simple III just
proves that white has big advantage
he's ready to play Knight g5 and and if
I don't have any attack he's just
clearly better here so so yeah he should
have taken and after this I guess the
game well I was deaf I definitely had an
initiative and honestly I thought that I
was winning but as I was told after the
game it was like slight advantage for
black like around this point that wasn't
very happy about my position after rook
c5 I thought I'm just winning but for
some reason as I've been told after
night before the evaluation computers
evaluation is only point 47 and blacks
favor I'm not quite sure why it to be
honest because I thought after Queen d8
I should be just winning
or at least at least well we can agree
that the game is basically either gonna
end up in a draw black is gonna win so
two results only impossible here they is
that if 96 is not working because night
I mean Queen g5 95 and later 4 and then
if Queen g3 than just 92 so I thought
here I should be really good probably
the best chance for black would have
been to take on h5 and then go into this
end game and try to survive although I'm
pretty optimistic that after 96 my I
guess I would have one like from humans
perspective these positions should be
winning
I thought although he told me after the
game that you know he was actually happy
about his position you know he thought
it's about equal unclear and I'm like I
thought I was winning so if you can see
the grandmasters and computers I mean
they evaluate the position sometimes
completely differently you know yeah and
after queen h5 probably here I should be
winning for sure after F 4 C 5 and then
Queen g5 is the most precise move
because like if if some something like
f3 then I wasn't so sure about this
maybe it's also winning somehow for
black but I thought this centralized my
queen is never a mistake
so Queen e5 what's good and then this is
it the game is over yeah that's pretty
much the end well Yara
congratulations on that victory and
we're happy to have you in st. Louis
again
now there's another tournament going on
around the world the World Cup of chess
128 player knockout and a lot of the
chess world is wondering where's yarrow
seated into the first round but you
elected not to play and your opponent
actually only shook I think wasn't it
got a walkover explain to the chess
world what exactly happened for your
withdrawal in the World Cup
well it's actually pretty discouraging
for me that I couldn't play so the
reason is that I'm applying for a green
card
and actually I submitted my petition
like a year ago and it has been a while
so I thought you know by now I should
have I should have got the response like
many many times now because I know some
of my friends apply to my god and they
got response like in three months after
the original application and when I was
signing the contract chances were
according to my lawyers is that hey you
should get it like by the end of August
for sure like I mean I mean it should be
there you know and some somehow I guess
I got unlucky and I'm still waiting so I
just couldn't go because the chances
were that I would not be able to make it
back I would not be allowed back to the
United States so that is a truly
unfortunate set of circumstances sorry
to hear that but that's that's the case
that's what's going on DRO thank you for
joining me one and a half to start let's
see where his contemporaries are in
Group A after the second round
joining yarrow in the top three in Group
A are daro spirits and Alexander Simonov
those last two players are in key games
tomorrow as round three will seed ro
spirits with white against Gehrig Myer
and Alexander Simonov with white against
roofing Lee we're early on here in the
second round in Group B and I have
Grandmaster Alejandro Ramirez who
already is the lone leader after two
rounds perfect two for two and today you
defeated knee chicken with the black
pieces tell us about the game and take
us through it
Bishop d3 really surprised me for some
reason I forgot that I could play wish'
page twice I actually saw it as soon as
I played Bishop g6 which was kind of
silly and after we should play Trevor
actually have no idea what she was
planning on doing I already thought if
three check is not a big deal because
just King f1 and then I remember that
after king of one action I'm controlling
enough to complain out of two and then
I'm just waiting obviously this is just
a fork so this was actually kind of
silly I forgot about we should page five
but Bishop e6 is also strong like the
son game is really emplacement four
white the para bishops is very strong
and her bishop on b2 is really bad
ninety four five ninety six ninety six
it's not pleasant to play but ninety
five might be a little bit better but
you have to reckon with ideas of like
Bishop c2 and eighty four or a4 first
it's really impressing ninety six and I
thought this was really strong takes
takes and Bishop c6 I can't play King I
can't play rook c8 because after rook d7
king of seven even though the Knights
trapped
she has Bishop a three and now I don't
have a good way of defending the bishop
on e7 so it's at least fine
visually six very strong question sixty
seven away from the night and after
ninety seven Ruby eight is it's very
dangerous tour especially in time
pressure because this end game after
takes takes ninety five might just be
lost for white she has to make sure that
takes takes us and lose immediately I
couldn't make it work for a black I
thought she had enough time to bring the
king dude either you foresee for and
play f3 which is important but still
it's a little scary and I don't have to
take on d5 obviously and just breaking
or seventeen e6 and torture her forever
which is what I was planning on doing 95
though allows me now to take on d5 and
there's a very big difference if she
takes on d5 with the rook then the same
game is actually lost she doesn't have
enough time to play f3 and defend the
King the pawn on
on d5 so she just loses either the pawn
on d5 or the pot on f2 so she has to
take leave on CD 5 but this is a very
emplacement time game I'm gonna blockade
with my king she cannot play king d well
she can't play kingly 3 and she should
have and I'm not sure I should take the
pawn but I can't take it upon if I
wanted to because after king he to chuck
I have Bishop before blocking the file
although this endgame I wasn't sure if
it was good for black like I thought
after Bishop takes takes rook c1 I
thought she could hold this
rockin game I wasn't going to take on d5
I was gonna play b5 but I always have
the threat of actually taking on d5 at
some point because I am Bishop before
Bishop c3 made my life really easy
though like at this point just opening
up the e-file for the rook is really
strong and she played and really severe
time pressure very not cured moves like
she should play rogue g3 and force my
idea of playing rookie 3 which exchanges
the rooks and then going into this
endgame keen to hear attacking this pawn
I'm not really sure she'd play King d3
or h3 I'll just put three there and play
the same game which is probably lost
because well I have an extra pawn and I
should be able to convert somehow but
it's not so clear but I thought after a
rookie former cage three route g4 I'm
very clearly winning g3 h6 as she can't
allow me to take on g2 she has to go g3
rook age 5 and I wrote g5 and then of
course there the question is this
endgame but because I'm trying to play
g4 and Bishop g1 she has to go here
which I lost my King to get all the way
to e4 and ours I was gonna have serious
doubts that she would be able to hold an
endgame with a king on e4 and and the
past F pawn I mean I wouldn't be like
horribly surprised but I'll be really
like I just thought it was my name
rook age 4 and then okay rocket fires a
little bit nice I'm throwing rock f2
Ritchie for doesn't really do much but
it helps her get closer to time control
but this is actually just lost I think I
mean I have so much activity the king is
very strong my rooks better than hers or
my business better than hers and this is
just a final combination to win the game
with each one each for
and then b5 so very nice move because
there she goes rook c1 well first rookie
force impossible because have five just
traps the rook rook c1 is impossible
because Bishop before forces a pawn
endgame as I'm gonna take everything
only one she's completely pinned now or
go into a bishop and game very similar
to what we're gonna see in the game
after Chuck and Keaney for which doesn't
really change much I wish it did in the
game which is rook c2 and after jack
takes bishop before winning a temple
she played this kind of clever hd5
because I cannot take only one as I
maybe she doesn't return on time but it
doesn't really change the game upon tech
stuff I both taking on g5 win there's a
path to king me for there should be 684
and she resigned because she's
completely paralyzed all I'm gonna do is
push this pawn here push this pawn here
put the King here and eventually when
she puts the bishop on c7 I'm gonna go a
bishop CSAT Bishop c5 Bishop f2 but
should be three and there's nothing she
can do about it
Wow a great start Alejandro
congratulations on that win again now
one of the other side stories of this
tournament there are several Saint Louis
University players here it's no secret
that you are the man behind the slough
chess team and I know you guys have only
had one meeting so far this year but
with the new incoming players the new
students at SLU what are your what's
your perspective on this year versus
last season well it's always difficult
to play a team the first time you're
together you still haven't fully formed
your team spirit you still have a lot of
kinks to to iron out a lot of even
bureaucratic inside and university
things that still weren't so clear but
now we're like we know each other better
the team is much closer
train together they're used to each
other they're stronger we have two new
players and one of them is our new first
board who's Henry Potter so I like our
chances a lot better than I did last
year and I know that the students are
working very hard including with the
participation in this tournament to
prepare for finance well I wish you the
best on that thank you for joining me a
great two rounds thus far let's take a
look how the rest of the field is doing
in Group B Alejandro is a frequent
commentator here at the Chess Club but
he's definitely not ready to retire
sitting atop with the perfect score
tomorrow
Alejandro takes on international master
personna in the key game of the day each
rounds notable players will be
interviewed in this recap but remember
to follow the games live every day at
1:00 p.m. in st. Louis via chess 24 and
us chess champs dot-com